steve barclay is the prime minister's
new chief of staff
he's already a minister and will now be
responsible for implementing the new
office of the prime minister
well it's all supposed to be a part of a
big clear out and reorganization at
number 10 in the wake of the partygate
scandal as a prime minister fights for
survival
so just how bad are things at number 10
and how will those that are left be
feeling
gavin barwell was theresa may's chief of
staff during some of the most turbulent
brexit years he joins me now
good morning lord barwell
now
given them
given that the prime minister was the
chief tormentor of your administration
can you tell me with a straight face
that you take no pleasure from his
present difficulties
yeah i can because i don't take any
pleasure of the difficulties that my
party is in at the moment and from the
point of view of the country uh you know
i don't think it's
anything anyone can take uh any pleasure
in at all trevor uh no it's not not an
out to shard and freud no temptation to
say i told you so because you did
right well so so there's a look i think
i'm we're perfectly entitled to warn uh
to say to people that the concerns that
we raised both about the brexit approach
the prime minister was going to take
you've just had an interview with
jeffrey donaldson there
uh teresa absolutely warned what a
border down the rsc might mean for our
politics so i think we're perfectly
entitled to take to say i told you so
but that's a different thing from what
you asked me which is do i take any
pleasure uh in seeing that the mess that
things are at the moment and i don't
okay well that's a very grown-up
approach um and of course that's why uh
the prime minister before previous prime
minister had you in there you were her
chief of staff um
steve barkley is your successor is that
a good appointment
so i've got a lot of time for steve i
think he's a really smart person uh
incredibly diligent uh he doesn't take
any nonsense he'll want high standards
there
i should declare an interest he's
someone i would consider a friend so
lots of good qualities that he has i
think that there are two challenges
the first is
he won't be able to do the job in the
way that i or nick timothy and fiona
hill or ed luellen or jonathan powell
did it because he's combining it with
being a government minister and an mp at
the same time so he's going to have to
find a way of doing the job in a
different way
and then the second challenge and i
think probably the key one
is whether the prime minister is going
to listen to the good advice that he
will give
you know a lot of the focus over the
last week or two has been about making
changes as downing street as if that
will
solve the problem it's worth
remembering that dan rosenfeld has just
announced he's standing down as chief of
staff
he was brought in by the prime minister
to clear up the previous mess in number
10. so there's only so much different
advisers can make
if the person at the top is not actually
listening to the advice that we're given
and to me
the most interesting thing about the
events of the last week or so
was minera murz's letter where it was
made clear that actually the prime
minister was told
by his advisors
not to make that smear about kierstarma
last monday
and ignored that advice and and a
statement that was meant to
show contrition and draw a line under
this story actually ended up making his
position so much worse
um just on on that point
um the business secretary just
a few minutes ago said to me that it
seemed a perfectly reasonable thing to
say in context
well i completely disagree with that i
mean if i if i imagine a high political
world where i had been advising boris
johnson before he went into the chamber
on monday
i would have said under no circumstances
either make any criticisms of your
opponents or make any excuses the job
today
is to go into the chamber and show
genuine contrition because that is your
only hope of drawing a line uh under
this story so i both think on an
intellectual level and a moral level
what he said was not acceptable i don't
want a politics there's enough there's
enough things trevor you'll know from
the people you interview there's enough
legitimate differences between us for
those to be the subject of political
debate and argument we don't want a
politics where people indulge in those
kind of smears but even if you set aside
that moral argument on a purely tactical
level it was a stupid thing for the
prime minister to do because it's led to
the resignation of one of his key aides
it's led to more letters more mps
submitting letters of no confidence in
him it's further
destabilized his position and the point
here is that he we know
he was given advice not to do that and
went ahead and did it anyway so what
that tells you is that yes having the
right people around you can help but
ultimately the culture in number 10 and
the decisions the government makes come
from the top and the prime minister
himself
if he's going to stay in office is going
to have to change the way he is behaving
and running the government
isn't the problem here then and i speak
to you as an experienced advisor
that actually
he doesn't take advice and you could
have socrates machiavelli
and whoever else you liked in there
to advice him
but he when he's got it in his head
won't take that advice cannot help
himself and he will do what he wants
isn't the problem here it's not the
advisors not the circle around him it's
the prime minister
so that that definitely has been the
problem and the question is whether it's
going to change the other person that
he's
bringing back into number uh bringing in
to number 10 is the new director of
communications good harry who was one of
his key advisors when he was mayor of
london so there was a period as you all
know from your own experience
when he was running london where first
with simon milton then with eddie lister
he had a team around him that he did
seem to to listen to and respect so it
is possible
uh that these changes you know he might
pay more attention to this new team than
he was to the previous one but you're
absolutely right about what the problem
has been up until now
uh it
i don't want to take too much time on
this specific point but
every time
one of these things happens you know
he says there was no party oh yes there
was a party uh i was another party oh
yes i was at the party uh
there's whatever it is about kirsten
that somebody says
uh he's going to change he says it's
going to change and then he does it all
over again
yes i think
at some point in the future when
someone's writing a book about how to
handle political scandals the events of
the last few months will be like chapter
one of how not to do it
now if you imagine a hypothetical world
where when this story was first raised
number 10 had quickly established the
facts put them out there issued a
genuinely contrite apology
that might have been okay to get through
that what is indisputable
is that the way that the truth has been
dragged out of them
over the last two or three months has
made this situation far far worse far
more damaging to the prime minister's
reputation we're at a point today
where this where somewhere between 60
and 70
of your viewers think the prime minister
should resign
and ultimately
you know whatever comes out of the
police investigation or the final
version of the sue grey report if he
can't turn those numbers around if his
personal polling remains where it is
today then conservative mps are going to
make a change sooner or later
well well you've been you've been kind
enough to be one of our viewers today um
where are you on that uh which side of
that line are you on should he go as the
60 or 70
and for the country so i am on on on on
the moral issue i find it very very
difficult to defend the way in which he
has run number 10 and the way in which
he has tried to cover up what's happened
and on the pragmatic test which your
viewers will probably have less sympathy
with about what's the right thing for
the conservative party to do
i am very skeptical
about whether it's going to be possible
for him to restore his standing up with
the british public so my inclination is
that the conservative party would be
better making a change
and i also think uh for the good of a
country in terms of trust and faith in
our politics there's a strong case for
change but it's not up to me to make a
decision ultimately this is a decision
uh that up until the next election at
least is one for conservative mps
well and it's a decision for him so if
you were his advisor
would you be saying
boris time's up i don't think there's uh
a chance in hell that the prime minister
is going to voluntarily resign he's
going to stay there uh unless
conservative mps remove him or unless he
loses an election uh and so
you know i don't see any prospect of him
voluntarily standing
downtrend gavin barwell thank you so
much for your time and your
experience this morning
my pleasure